SPEAKER 1: Hello, everyone.
Welcome.
So we are very happy
to have Mathew here,
along with his mother
Jane, and his former
adversary-turned-friend, Sam,
for this really special talk
on an important topic.
So, today, you will hear
Mathew's story about coming out
at 16, his five-year experience
with conversion therapy,
and his journey of
finding peace afterwards.
So, today, along
with his mother,
Mathew is a national
advocate for banning
these destructive practices, and
is a full-time advisory member
of the Born Perfect
Campaign with the National
Center for Lesbian Rights.
So please join me in
welcoming Matt to the stage.
Mathew.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: Whoo!
MATHEW SHURKA: Thank you.
SPEAKER 1: Ah, sorry.
[LAUGHS]
MATHEW SHURKA: Hi.
Thank you, [? Cat, ?]
for that introduction.
And happy pride, everyone.
[CHUCKLES]
[APPLAUSE]
Yes.
That deserves a
round of applause.
So I had a difficult
time figuring out
how I was going
to give this talk,
because when you go through
conversion therapy for five
years, and are moved
around the country in four
different states,
having psychotherapists
trying to cure me of my
homosexuality, a lot happens.
And it's not just
the impact on myself,
but on the impact of
all the lives around me,
especially my
family, my friends.
And the impact that I
have until this very day.
So I figured I'm going to
start with what happened right
before I entered
conversion therapy
and how did I get there.
So I grew up in
Great Neck, New York.
If anyone knows where that
is, it's, like, awesome.
OK, great, you're
like my neighbor.
And it's 30 minutes from here.
So I'm a local to
New York, for anyone
who doesn't know where that is.
And when I was in high school,
I was fooling around with boys.
I started maybe
in seventh grade.
I thought it was awesome.
I didn't have any shame
or any guilt about it.
And I didn't have
any reason to have
any shame or guilt about it.
But when I got into high
school, that totally
shifted what that meant to me.
I noticed that all the
seniors and upperclassmen
were bigger, taller, hairier.
And I was like, oh, my
god, these guys are men.
And it scared me, because
all they were doing
was competing for all
the freshman girls.
And I did not relate
to that at all.
And so I was like, how
am I going to fit in?
I don't have that many friends.
And all I wanted to do was
get accepted and fit in.
And I knew that I
had this stomach
pit feeling that I'm gay.
And I don't know
what to do about it.
And I just became a
person who was in denial.
And so [INAUDIBLE]
the first pictures.
These are my parents.
And it's a funny picture.
That's my parents on vacations.
And my parents-- my
father's Middle Eastern.
My mom's American.
And Great Neck is a really
Jewish, conservative, Middle
Eastern community.
And my father built--
when he settled there
about a year before I was born,
my father built his dream home.
And it's this pretty
outlandish house.
It's really
architecturally beautiful,
and really inspired me for
architectural design as well.
And it really began
to play in my role
of hiding my sexuality as well.
And my freshman year of high
school, I became the party guy.
What started off as, like,
just having a few friends
over on a Saturday night
turned into 10 friends.
And 10 to 20, 50, and I was
well over 100 teenagers all
partying at my house.
And I became popular.
I thought I was
in the "in crowd."
I felt accepted.
I felt like, OK,
this is working.
But I really had no personal
connection to anyone.
My two best friends
were two guys
that lived right
near me, who went
to a different high school.
And those were the two guys I
hung out with on the weekends.
So I was already living
like multiple lives.
And as I began these parties,
I was lying to my parents.
My parents were really outgoing,
so on any Saturday night,
they'd be out till 3:00,
4:00 in the morning.
So I had enough time to have a
party and to get everyone out,
and I would be fine.
I got caught a few times,
but more or less it worked.
And so I'm creating
a reputation,
I'm creating a persona for
who I am in high school.
And there's two guys who are
in the grade above me, Sam
and Steven.
And now, they had a reputation
of being troublemakers.
You know, if they're ever
going to be at your house,
they have the possibility
of trashing your house.
And it's not really someone you
wanted be on their bad side.
So I didn't really know them,
so it didn't really bother me.
I was like, OK, if
I ever have a party,
they're just not
going to be there.
And I'll be fine.
But as my parties got
bigger and bigger,
it was more than just my
grade, the whole high school
would come to my parties.
And I blatantly made sure that
these two guys were not there.
So you can imagine this
made them very angry.
And it started like a couple
years of turmoil between us.
There was a few
moments of aggravation.
They had tried coming
to my house at a party,
I kicked them out.
They tried throwing
a party in my house.
I stopped it.
And it became like
popularity war between us.
And all I cared about
was no one finding out
that I might be gay.
That's the only thing
that was on my mind.
And as this continued, I'm
now a junior in high school,
and it was the first
Friday of school.
So Sam and Steven
are now seniors,
and that's a really big deal.
You know, senioritis.
And it was the first Friday.
My parents had-- we had
a maid, a live-in maid.
And I had a junior's
license, so I just
drove with her everywhere,
because I could drive.
And so it was after school.
I'm driving, and I
pull up to a stop sign,
and I see Sam and Steven
crossing the crosswalk.
And Steven starts yelling at me,
hey, man, oh, look who it is.
It's Matt Shurka.
Why don't you hit me
with your car, bro?
And I'm, like,
this is ridiculous.
These guys have been
fighting with me.
It's a new school year.
And here we go again.
And I roll down my window, and
as I passed them, I yelled out,
that's right, you
fucking faggots.
And I drove off.
I had lost myself
in that persona
of making sure that no one
knew what I was dealing with.
I was hooking up
with guys secretly.
And I became the guy at
school who wanted to fit in.
So, "bro," "fag,"
"that's so gay,"
were all a part
of my vocabulary.
And I thought it was
really, really smart,
because then I would just blend
in and no one would notice.
An hour after I called
Sam and Steven faggots,
I was in the ER.
And I got a blow to the face,
followed to the barbershop.
And when I was in
the hospital, my nose
was about a half inch
to the right of my face.
My nose had six separate
breaks, and a gash from my nose
up to my eyebrow.
And let's see, so this
is actually the house.
So I don't ever--
I don't usually
show a picture of my house, but
its so you get the idea, like,
I had hundreds of
teenagers partying here
without my parents knowing.
This is the inside.
You know, so I was
getting away with a lot.
And the day-- during
while I was healing,
this is the process
of what happened as I
was healing from the fight.
So this is me in
my bedroom at home.
And this is the Monday of
my first day back at school.
And I thought I was so tough.
I was like, I don't care,
I'm going to school.
And I walk through the
hallways like that.
Yeah, I healed.
I was fine.
And my nose got better.
That's me as a senior.
No plastic surgery.
It was totally cool.
That was a rumor that everyone
started in high school,
that oh, Matt got a nose job.
But yeah, so-- but
what really happened
that day was that I couldn't
help but think that I got
ambushed by all the senior guys.
And I knew that I was
gay and it meant so much
to my masculinity.
You know, if they
knew that I was gay,
my fear is what would
have happened then.
And it scared me.
So for two months
after that fight,
I was cutting school
almost every single day.
My parents could not understand
what I was acting out about.
And my father had a
conversation of me,
really pressing for me to share
what is going on in your life.
And I told him I think I'm gay.
I've been seeing other guys at
school, the other closeted guys
at school.
I know I've been with
girls, but I just really
don't know what to do.
I know this is what I like.
And my dad was so awesome.
My dad said, you know, I
love you no matter what.
I'm always going to
be there for you.
And I thought I was
golden after that.
So literally the very next
day, my father freaked out.
He had his own
little panic of what
it meant to have a gay son.
And he started searching in the
New York area for therapists.
And he came across a
conversion therapist
who told him, well, there is
no such thing as homosexuality.
And it's all part
of childhood trauma.
Everyone is born
innately heterosexual.
And because your son is still
young and still inexperienced
sexually, you'll start to see
his heterosexuality come back
in six weeks.
My dad was thrilled.
He found an opportunity
of a lifetime.
And so out of my fear of
ever getting hurt again,
trusting my father,
and his love for me,
I began conversion therapy.
It was five years I was
in conversion therapy,
so obviously, the six
weeks didn't really work.
And just to really say what
conversion therapy was like.
So you have to blame someone
in conversion therapy.
If you're not born gay,
it came from somewhere.
So I had a really
fortunate upbringing.
I had no trauma.
My parents were great.
They loved me.
They spoiled me, if anything.
But I had to look for it.
I'm the only son,
so the first guess
was I have too much
female in my life.
So what I had to do was I had to
spend as much time as possible
with the other guys at
school, so I can learn
about masculinity,
learn what it's
like to relate to other guys.
Simultaneously, I had to
avoid women at all costs.
These are the first steps
of curing homosexuality.
[LAUGHTER]
I met my first boyfriend
this way, by the way.
And unfortunately, though,
what that included was
I actually didn't speak to
my mother and my two sisters
for three years.
Now what does that
actually mean?
My mother was never going to
actually physically separate
from me, so we lived
in the same house,
and I didn't talk to
her for three years.
So I would wake
up in the morning,
mom would make me breakfast.
I come down, eat breakfast,
I'd walk right out the door.
And that's what life was like.
My mom-- both my
parents, I would say,
were naive about it, about
what is homosexuality
and what to do and are
following the guidance
of a state-licensed therapist.
And I was the one who actually
became the police officer
in my own home.
When my mom started to see
that this is actually crazy,
there can't be any
therapy out there
that separates a
child and its mother,
she would actually try and talk
to me and tell me, I love you,
however you are.
If you're gay or not, it's OK.
And I would throw
a tantrum at her.
You know, how dare you.
Because I looked at her as
a cause of my homosexuality.
And now she's
ruining the therapy
that I think is-- if I had
to save my life in order
to become straight.
So as much as my
own mother tried,
I was the one making sure
that she was not going
to get close to me at all.
So the years went on,
I became more popular.
I actually now was
getting training
by my conversion therapists,
based on stereotypes
of how to be a guy.
I did very well at it.
However, my depression grew.
My grades failed.
I was almost-- I was pretty
much a straight-A student
before my conversion
therapy, and I almost
failed out of high school.
And there was a period,
probably after my senior year
where I contemplated my possible
suicide for about two years.
Thought about when, where, how.
I even shared it with
a friend, like, oh, I
had this dream, just to see
what their reaction would be.
And they laughed it off.
No one really could
take it seriously.
But it was something
that was real,
because I knew I wasn't
becoming more straight.
As I became more of a man,
my interest in men only grew.
I knew exactly what I
wanted and what I liked.
And so the years went on.
I attempted to have
my first boyfriend.
I told my conversion therapist
and my father every detail.
And actually, my first boyfriend
disappeared and broke up
with me.
Not knowing why, and
I later found out
that my father had met with
him and threatened him.
And it was a friend
of mine growing up.
When that happened, I
was just losing trust
in everyone around me.
I felt conspired against.
I didn't trust the therapist.
I found that he was lying to me.
My own mother and sisters
knew why my boyfriend had
disappeared, but I
wasn't talking to them,
so it's not like they were
going to tell me anyway.
And I moved.
I moved to Los Angeles
to get away from it all.
And for the next couple
years, I was in and out
of therapy, conversion therapy.
And there was a pattern
that I was picking up on,
which was every
conversion therapist I
met had the same story.
They were gay themselves.
They cured themselves.
And that's how they became one.
So I was like, wait a second.
Have I actually ever
met someone who's
converted to heterosexuality?
And I never met a single
person till this day.
I've met men who were
in conversion therapy,
married, and had children.
And they say, yeah, I still
have my attractions to men.
I just don't do
anything about it.
And they literally
treat their attractions
to other men like alcoholism.
It's there, notice it,
don't do anything about it.
And that's when I really
started to question everything
around me.
The very thing that
I believed in so much
and was really
trying to make work.
And I finally had enough.
And at the age of 21, estranged
from my father that point,
I haven't spoken to my mother
in three years nor my sisters,
I left conversion therapy
and moved back to New York.
I became a server
here at a restaurant
in SoHo called Balthazar, and
it was a great experience.
I had a boss that was gay.
I had clientele who were out.
You know, executives.
And it was really
just inspiring to see
people living their life,
successful in whatever they're
doing.
And whatever their
sexual orientation is
had made no difference
to their life.
So after that, I was able to
actually see a psychotherapist
for the first time.
I had actually never seen
one, an actual person
who does therapy.
And it's a-- [LAUGHS] and
it took a lot of trust.
It was a new experience for me.
I also did a program
called Landmark,
which is a global personal and
professional training company.
And I got so inspired
from there by mentors,
and I started to
look at my own life.
How my whole life I
was trying to fit in.
And I noticed that the
conversion therapists
who were treating me were trying
to fit in, in their own life.
And my father who I hadn't
spoken to in five years
was trying to be a great dad.
Now I didn't believe
that for a long time.
And I went and spoke to him.
So it was in 2012.
I hadn't seen my
dad in five years.
My father moved back to
Israel where he's from.
And I had a
conversation with him.
And I said to my dad,
I want to see you.
It's been five years.
Can I come and see you?
I'm going to fly to Israel.
And I flew there.
I was only there for three days.
And I was with my
whole family there.
Everyone is there.
And we had dinner together.
And I made a gay
joke at the table.
Everyone laughs except my dad.
And my dad said to me, you
know, let's take a walk.
And he looked--
and he said to me--
we walked away from the table.
And he said to me, so, whatever
happened to your conversion
therapy?
Are you gay?
Are you not?
It sounds like
you're openly gay.
And I said, yeah, dad.
I've met some really great
people, some really inspiring
people, and this is who I am.
I am openly gay.
And my dad started this
rant-- which he always says,
I probably have it memorized--
how I can't be gay,
I don't understand
what the world is,
and I'm going to hurt myself.
And my automatic reaction
would be to like fight with him
verbally to stop this.
But I just listen.
And it was for the first
time, through all my work
and all my healing,
I was able to hear
how scared my father was.
My dad was terrified.
I'm his only son, he had no
idea what to do about this.
And I stopped him after 10
minutes of him rambling on.
And I said, dad, there is
nothing to worry about.
Now, I've never actually
looked at my dad in the eye
and said there's
nothing to worry about.
I don't know if anyone
really tells their parents,
guys, it's OK, mom and dad.
And he looked at me, he's
like, how can you say that?
How can you say not to worry?
And I was, like, dad, I know
exactly what the world is.
I know exactly who I am.
And my promise to you is
I will take care of myself
as it comes.
There's really nothing
to worry about.
Look around.
We're here together for the
first time in five years.
Is there anything
wrong happening?
And my father said, OK.
Now what happened in that
moment was I got my father back,
and I recognized
that I was never
going to-- I was never going
to sacrifice my relationship
with my father ever again.
Now this doesn't
mean my father's
going to march on Fifth
Avenue during gay pride.
That's the last thing
he's going to do.
But what started, what
opened up was a conversation.
And my dad is someone I
talk to almost every day.
And when he has questions or
things he doesn't-- that he
can't work out for himself
about me being openly gay,
we talk about it.
And that's just
how it looks like.
And it's great.
The next person I
wanted to reach out
to make peace to, or start a
conversation [INAUDIBLE] what
is going to happen
was one therapist
who treated me for three years.
And this man was
living in Los Angeles.
And I didn't know what
he was going to say,
so I sent an email.
And said to him,
hey, I would love
to share a conversation with
you and share my accomplishments
since we last met.
Would you be interested?
He didn't answer
the email, he just
called me 15 minutes later.
And I had a heart attack.
And I didn't pick up the call.
He called again, maybe
another 30 minutes later.
I'm, like, just get on the call.
I started this.
And it was just like,
hi, how are you?
And I shared with him
all my accomplishments.
I shared with him
how I came out,
how I told my dad not to worry,
that life's going to be OK.
And I told him that I'm
going to become a gay rights
advocate, because I made a
YouTube video that just went
viral, and I just got invited to
speak at Creating Change, which
is a national LGBT conference.
And he said, wow.
He said, you know, you're
one of-- he started to share,
you're one of 13 guys I
treated who I never cured.
I said, OK.
So does that mean you're
not practicing anymore?
And he started to
share with me how
he was in a really
bad place in his life.
He spent all his money going
to school, getting a PhD.
And the last thing he thought
he was doing was hurting people.
And he says, I don't
actually really know
the full damage of what I did.
And he has a wife and two
kids, and people won't even
hire me right now.
And I don't even
know what to do.
What was interesting was
the tables sort of turned.
I now was the
therapist, in a way.
And he was like the
patient seeking help.
And I just really got
the humanity in him.
And we started to talk every
week and just became friendly.
And I shared with him that I
know I'm going to be speaking.
I'm going to be
sharing our story.
My years with you, I
really cared about you.
I believe there was
some of the best time.
I didn't realize the harm that
was happening to me because I
believed in the therapy.
And I said, do I
get your-- will I
have your blessing to go speak
nationally about this issue?
And he said, of course.
And please tell me
everything that happens.
We started to become friendlier.
And as time went by, a lot
was going on in the country.
Conversion therapy
became a national topic.
It almost pretty much
did not exist before.
And there was a big
lawsuit that started.
I was invited to be a part
of against a few conversion
therapists, some
that had treated me.
And I declined to
be a part of it.
And instead, I asked
this particular therapist
if he would join
me in an interview.
We get to share
our story together.
Former patient,
former therapist.
And we created an
article-- I believe it's
the next slide-- this article.
And it says, "True Colors,
Getting Over the Gay Cure."
And we sat side by side--
it was the first time we
saw each other in five years--
and we talked about, together,
what conversion therapy
was like for both of us.
And I just recognized
the impact of this versus
if he was behind a bench
and I was suing him.
And I was actually
standing for him.
I wanted him to get the
life that he wanted to live
and what he was-- why
did he go to school?
Why did he become a therapist?
I became interested in
what he wanted in his life.
And we got to create this
incredible article together.
So as time went on, I
am now a advisory member
to a campaign called-- it's
a hashtag-- #BornPerfect.
It was created by
the National Center
for Lesbian Rights
in San Francisco.
And our goal is by
2019 we will end
conversion therapy nationwide.
Our advocacy has continued.
So far, conversion therapy has
been outlawed in six US states
for minors only.
And we have federal legislation
right now pending in Congress.
Considering that this movement
has only started in two years,
our progress has
been outstanding.
And we really believe that
by 2019, conversion therapy
will be outlawed.
This is just another article.
This is me when I--
in "Time" magazine, I
wrote an op-ed for "Time."
And that's when I was
speaking in Albany.
I got really-- it's punked.
I put my-- I don't know how my
hands got in the air like that,
actually.
It's a conversion
therapy. [LAUGHS]
So what I want to do next
is-- my mother is here.
My mother is awesome,
and I cherish my mother.
Everyone who's a survivor
of conversion therapy--
we call them
survivors-- it really
is something that you survive.
Because the LGBT suicide
rate is very high.
It's about five times higher
than straight individuals.
If you're in conversion
therapy, you're
eight times more likely
to commit suicide
on top of the LGBT rate.
And there are stories
like Leelah Alcorn who
made national news last
year-- a teenager who
was in conversion therapy.
It's happening every day.
It's phone calls
I get every day.
It's Facebook messages
It's emails I get every day.
Help, what can I do?
I'm in this country.
I'm in this state.
We just had a teenage
girl who would
be removed from a conversion
therapy facility in Texas
yesterday.
So this is like a real
thing that's happening.
And it's being
spoken about more.
So my mom didn't go
through conversion therapy,
but she went through a
horrific experience with me.
And what she survived
was the advice
that my conversion
therapist gave me.
So what I'm going
to do is I'm going
to have my mom, who's here,
she's going to come on stage.
And I'm going to have her
share a little bit about what
her experience is like as a mom.
And ask her some
questions as well.
So please-- Jane is her name--
[APPLAUSE]
--come on stage.
Why don't you sit here?
Yes.
It's not every day
I get to interview
my mom like this, so welcome.
So I didn't even-- I never-- I
never actually came out to you.
I only came out to dad.
And I began conversion therapy.
Why don't you-- what
was that like when
dad said to you that I was going
to be in conversion therapy?
What were your thoughts
about it at first,
and when did you realize that
this is not something you
thought maybe was best for me.
Or you share what that was like.
JANE SHURKA: I felt
that you had issues.
I never felt that you were
gay when you were growing up.
And I said, OK, you have issues.
OK, he tells me you're gay.
That's the issue.
OK, that's fine.
And my attitude was
that he's telling me
he's going to conversion
therapy because he told me
you were confused.
You felt confused.
So I said, me not knowing about
being gay, I said he's confused
and he wants help.
So I'll go for it.
Let him try to get a
conversion therapist
and help you to be straight,
if that's what you wanted.
MATHEW SHURKA: Sure.
And then what happened next?
What happened in
the coming months?
JANE SHURKA: OK, so he searched
for a conversion therapist.
He was telling me the
conversion therapist is--
said you're-- there's no
such thing as being gay.
And I believe that
you're born gay.
That was my belief.
That's the only
knowledge that I did
have, is that I felt
that you were born gay.
But didn't know
anything else about it.
And when he said, six weeks
you're going to be straight,
I said, OK.
I think that's OK.
MATHEW SHURKA: Sounds
like a good deal.
JANE SHURKA: I-- you
know, sounds good.
I said, he's going to-- your
father was very upset by it,
and I said OK.
If it's going to
help you, I agree.
MATHEW SHURKA: OK.
As you know, I said
earlier that you
were trying to-- you wanted me
to recognize that it was OK.
And I was furious every
time you did that.
JANE SHURKA: Look,
before the six weeks,
I knew that you were gay.
I started to
understand what is gay.
MATHEW SHURKA: Speak
into the microphone.
Speak into the microphone.
JANE SHURKA: I understood-- now,
I started really looking at you
and seeing this is not working.
MATHEW SHURKA: I
don't know-- OK.
I don't want to know the
evidence of that, but--
JANE SHURKA: I understood,
as a mom knows her child,
and understands things, and I
understood that you were gay.
And I wanted you to
accept yourself as gay.
The treatment was crazy.
I felt it was crazy.
But, I said, I don't
want to give up, either.
It was six weeks into treatment.
I say, you have to keep trying,
maybe we have to work this out.
But I just saw as time went
on, that this is not working.
And it's not helpful.
MATHEW SHURKA: What about--
we talk about six weeks,
and I was in it for five years.
What happened
between you and dad?
You and dad, you got divorced.
And I know that was
something separate.
But did you think, you
know, it really started it
when conversion therapy started.
I know you and dad
had your own things,
but you guys had a
huge difference--
you and dad had a huge
difference about what
was happening to me.
We were a really close family.
We grew up as a family
having Shabbat dinners, which
is something we do
as a Jewish family.
There's like 30 of
us every Friday.
And yet, I was
coming home every day
not talking to Melanie
and Nancy, my two sisters.
Where did you think
it was all going?
I remember when--
yeah, where did you
think that was all going?
JANE SHURKA: First of all, I
was going through a divorce
with your father.
Nothing to do with you.
So I had a lot of
emotional issues myself.
And I went to therapy to
help me get my act together.
And through that time
with therapy for myself,
I saw that this is
not good for you.
And that you're
not talking to me
and I try to
communicate with you.
I was praying every day for you
to come out and be yourself.
Because it was just a
terrible place for you.
I was sitting there,
realizing people
take for granted when they
wake up every day that they-- I
don't think about my sexuality.
I never thought about it.
I wake up, I know who I am.
You were arguing with
yourself every day.
And I just can't imagine
being in that situation.
And I saw you, that this
is not the way to be.
That you have to accept
yourself the way you are.
And it just-- with the
conversion therapist
helping you all the
time and telling you--
this man who has a
license-- is telling you,
maybe he knows better than I do.
I I'm realizing he doesn't.
And he has a license and
we're respecting the fact
that he has more
knowledge than I have,
that he's more
educated than I am.
MATHEW SHURKA: Yeah.
You doubted yourself based
on his own credentials.
JANE SHURKA: Yes.
Yes.
MATHEW SHURKA: I going
to ask one last question
and then move on.
When you saw my You-- so,
my first-- I never even
had a YouTube account,
and I made one,
and it was the first
time I ever made a video.
I made it for the It
Gets Better project,
which is for anti-bullying
of LGBT teens.
And the video, it went viral.
It's not like it has
millions of hits,
but it went viral
within 24 hours
and it ended up on the
cover, the gay voices
of "The Huffington
Post" website.
And that's really where
my advocacy began.
What was your reaction
when you saw the video?
JANE SHURKA: I cried.
I cried from-- I said, thank
god that you-- this is--
you're not going back.
You cannot deny you
are gay anymore.
Thousands of people
are looking at this.
And it was a monumental
moment for me,
for us, to finally
accept yourself.
I was proud of you.
I was so happy that you
finally came to terms,
because now we're going
to go in a good direction.
Now we're going to be
in the right place.
MATHEW SHURKA: Yeah, I didn't
expect that video to end up
on the news, but, [INAUDIBLE].
JANE SHURKA: It was all over.
MATHEW SHURKA: But it--
yes, I wasn't going back.
JANE SHURKA: [INAUDIBLE].
MATHEW SHURKA: OK.
JANE SHURKA: I'd just like to
say why I'm here as a parent.
That I want to help other
parents-- because there's
other parents in this world, in
this life, that thinks the way
I thought.
They're ignorant,
they don't understand,
and I think it's so important
to accept your child.
When he tells you that
I'm gay, he's gay.
Not making any excuses, he
doesn't-- he's not confused.
He is gay, and you should
help him find himself
in that direction.
And when you do that, you
will have-- your child--
I wouldn't-- you wouldn't
lose your child to five years
of conversion therapy.
He lost very formative years
in his life for that therapy.
Thank god he didn't
lose it altogether.
But I think it's so
important, me, as a parent,
to put out there to all the
other parents in this world,
that you should
accept your children
and love them and accept
them the way they are.
[APPLAUSE]
MATHEW SHURKA: Thank you.
You can sit-- you can sit there.
Thanks, mom.
I almost debated
about bringing her.
But that was so great.
And the fact that
we started-- my mom
advocated me only last
year the first time.
And I never even considered
that could be possible
that I would advocate
publicly with my mom.
So just, thank you
for being so open.
And this was such a personal
experience for our family.
So I shared with you how I
reached out to my father.
My father is-- he and
I are very close today.
He lives in Israel.
I reached out to my
conversion therapist.
He's no longer practicing
conversion therapy
and he's moving on in his life.
The last person I
reached out to was Sam.
Sam was the high school student
who ended up breaking my nose.
And I considered, like,
why was I calling him?
And I wanted to call
because I was apologizing
for calling him a faggot.
And that I was so lost, and
so-- I was only concerned
about myself, about no
one ever finding out,
I wasn't even considering
what my actions
were doing to other people.
And so Sam joined us today.
Sam has become a friend of mine.
And he flew in just to be here,
he flew in from Los Angeles.
This is the first time we're
ever speaking together.
We've had numerous phone calls.
We met-- the first time
we met was in 2013.
And I discovered
an incredible man.
And he's flourishing
in his career
and he's living a great life.
So it's a privilege
that he joined us
today and can be here.
So I'm going to write Sam
to come onto the stage.
And I'm going to
ask him questions.
[APPLAUSE]
Welcome.
SAM MINER: Thank you.
MATHEW SHURKA: Thank
you for being here.
This is so exciting for me,
and I know we spoke, for us.
So I guess the
first question I'm
going to ask you is what
were you like in high school?
SAM MINER: Well, I felt I was a
popular person in high school,
not like your jock
or class president.
I didn't do good in school
and I didn't play sports,
but me and all my
friends, we were just
focused about who could
have the biggest party, who
could do the most drugs, who
could hook up with the best
girls, and who could dominate
in fights and things like that,
and just trying to build
a reputation around more
destructive things at the time.
MATHEW SHURKA: Yeah.
I mean, yeah.
[LAUGHTER]
Yeah, I thought that-- I
had a reputation for you.
Yeah, I had no
relationship to you.
Of course, I knew who
you were, I knew of you.
You're Sam and-- yeah
otherwise, I actually never
knew you personally.
So this is who you were in
high school, and so who was I?
Who was Matt Shurka?
You know, I know you moved
from a private Jewish school
and came to our school.
Who was I when-- I don't know
if we ever recall when we first
met, but, yeah.
Who was I to you?
SAM MINER: So Matt
was this rich kid,
who would throw these crazy
parties in his insane house.
And they would grow bigger
and bigger every single year.
And it was the only party
we weren't invited to.
So obviously, this
made us pretty angry.
And finally, there was an
event in school called Battle.
And it's battle of the classes.
MATHEW SHURKA: They call it
War for high school students.
SAM MINER: And usually one
person has like an open house
party where everybody in the
entire school is invited.
So me and my friends,
we thought we would go
and tons of cars outside,
like the whole street,
maybe like 100 cars.
And people just standing outside
and waiting for the party
to start.
So me, Steven, a few
of our other friends,
we get up to the front door.
And I don't know why you weren't
so busy that you actually
opened the door, but
Matt opens the door,
and is just like--
doesn't say anything,
he's just like, you guys
aren't allowed in here.
And I was so furious, I
remember I just reached
in and just tried to hit him.
And somebody pulled him back,
and then they shut the door.
And we just left.
So that was my
experience with you,
and it was just-- I couldn't
understand why we wouldn't
be invited to your parties.
I mean, I thought that
there was something wrong--
you thought there's
something wrong with us--
MATHEW SHURKA: Yeah.
SAM MINER: --that we
couldn't come and enjoy.
MATHEW SHURKA: Yeah, it's
interesting when you hear that.
That was all before,
but this is, like,
what was leading to the
actual time I got hit.
And yeah, I just wanted--
it's so interesting
to hear-- when I heard you
say that and I called you
a couple years ago, I just
wanted to make sure that I was
getting along with
everyone, and you not being
in my home was like, OK,
just trying to make sure
they're not there.
You know, it never
even crossed my mind
that, like, our whole high
school's going to be there
and I'm not there.
What's going on?
I was so preoccupied with that.
So it was a year later
when you were a senior
and I was a junior.
And we actually got into our-- I
guess we're calling it a fight.
I guess, if you want to share
what that was like for you?
And more so, what
it meant to you.
Like what the impact
was of the fight.
If you want to give
a little bit of both.
SAM MINER: Sure.
So at that time, I had already
got in a lot of trouble,
and I'd been arrested
a number of times.
And I wanted to start my
senior year and turn a new leaf
and just avoid trouble,
arrest at all costs.
And it was the third day
of school on a Friday,
and everybody was excited,
obviously, to leave.
It was the excitement
of your senior year.
And we were-- all
our friends were just
going to get together
and go have fun.
So we stepped off
school property,
and immediately we
see Matt to our left.
My friend, Steven, who's much
more of a loudmouth than I am,
started yelling at
Matt some things.
And I remember Matt just
looking at us with disgust,
like for some reason,
he just hated us.
And then as he's driving by,
he rolls down his window,
he says what he said,
and we follow him.
We follow him to the barbershop.
And I'm staying
across the street.
I'm just thinking, I don't
want to be involved in this,
I don't want to get in trouble.
But Steven runs
across the street
and runs into the
barbershop, and I'm like-- me
and Steven have been
through everything together.
We felt-- we always
would rile each other up,
because we always
felt the same way.
We always felt we were
outcast, troublemakers,
and couldn't get along
in a regular society
that we were in.
So the second I approached
the door to the barbershop,
I just hear yelling,
Matt and Steven.
And I see Matt come at
me, my first instinct
was just to throw punches.
So I hit Matt.
I hear a big bang.
And then I see Matt's eyes
roll to the back of his head,
and I see his nose split open.
I see the bone.
I see a little bit of blood.
And then I see him
drop to his knees.
And it was the scariest
moment of my life.
I thought I saw a ghost.
And I thought that day
that I killed somebody.
And I thought that I've
already been arrested,
I've already been in
trouble, I'm never
going to get through this.
I just ruined the
rest of my life.
We went so far as after that,
we went to my friend's house,
and I told Steven to
hit me multiple times
so he could claim self-defense.
And that didn't work.
MATHEW SHURKA: Well, thank
you for sharing that so openly
and being vulnerable.
Yeah, I mean, that
was the last day
you attended our high school.
You know, that was a Friday
and Monday you weren't there.
One of the things I
said to you on the phone
was-- when I called you and
apologized, I'm like, you know,
Sam, I didn't know
who you were before.
I didn't know who you-- I
don't know who you are today.
I know nothing
about you, actually.
We were never friends.
And yet, I said to you,
you were the single person
who's had the greatest impact
in my life till this very day.
And I don't know who you are.
And I said, I don't
know what it was
like that you didn't
graduate with us, your class,
you didn't go to prom, you
weren't a part of any of that.
I heard rumors that maybe
you were in jail, maybe
you were not.
And I said things like had
so many options of what
I could have done that day.
I didn't have to
roll down the window
and yell out the word "faggot."
I could have just
kept to myself.
I couldn't even-- our whole--
all of our friends took sides,
parents in our
community took sides.
It was like such
a massive impact
to what happened that day.
And taking it-- just
to stop being worried
about if I'm gay or not
and people finding out,
and considering
other people, I said,
I could have actually been
there for you as friends.
And we could have
actually resolved this.
But what ended up happening
was our friends ended up
fighting with all of each other
as well as the years went on.
And I know I took
on that perspective,
and I wanted it-- I took
on the idea of being
responsible in every
aspect that, yeah, I
went through conversion therapy
and I'm a gay rights advocate
today, but I was a
person who used the word
"faggot" towards
others, not really
considering what that meant.
And I don't know--
because of that fight,
I don't know-- it was
because of that fight
that actually I came out.
I was a person in denial.
And when that fight happened,
it was like the moment
where I can't hide this anymore.
I'm scared.
The fact that there's
a group of guys
that are able that do that, is
like, what am I actually going
to do with my life.
And so it's funny how
things work out in life
is that it was because of
that fight that I came out.
Yes, I had to go to
the conversion therapy
and get to where I was, but I
might have been in the closet
for years, knowing the
community we come from.
My first boyfriend
is still closeted.
You know, and he
was my boyfriend.
And yes, I look back at it like
it was a huge moment for me.
And I want to ask, I got to
hear a little bit about where
your life went afterwards.
And so what did
happen afterwards?
And where did that
take you today?
And who are you today?
SAM MINER: Well, just
that moment in the fight,
it was-- I already wanted to
avoid trouble at all costs.
It was also a big
turning moment for me,
because I just had
this sense that I
had to make a massive
change in my life
and redirect all my energies.
And that meant a major overhaul.
Like changing who I was, really.
My friends were what
I did every day.
So where I went-- I was sent to
this therapeutic troubled teen
program in the wilderness.
It was either that or jail.
MATTHEW SHURKA: Yeah,
this was a court order.
SAM MINER: A court order.
And so there, unexpectedly,
I had a moment to be free.
This was a place
where you literally
live in the wilderness.
You live off the land.
You make your own fires,
not with a lighter,
with like local materials.
You only eat rice,
lentils, just basic things.
And you are surrounded
by strangers.
And all these people
that you get to know,
you realize that they're all
just fighting for attention.
And I had the time to
reflect that everything
that I was doing
was to gain the love
and appreciation
of others, and just
build my personal confidence
in the society that I was in.
So I had a moment
to take a step back,
and to sort of think
about how I wanted
to direct my energies into
something more positive.
And really I was
able to have the time
to make those personal changes
before I came back home
and taking a new path.
MATTHEW SHURKA: Yeah.
That was so surprising.
So that was the last
thing I was going
to-- this is the last thing
I thought to hear, like,
you had a court
order, and you said,
you hated when you got there
and you walked away loving it.
That's what you told me,
and the impact it has.
And so you live in
Los Angeles today.
What do you-- just want to
share briefly what you do.
SAM MINER: So I'm
a project manager
at a company called [? Ucero. ?]
They're a venture-backed food
tech startup based
in San Francisco,
but we have an operational
facility in Los Angeles
that I went to help build.
So it's been a very
exciting time there.
We make cold-pressed
juice and try
to help the world by
selling organic products.
MATTHEW SHURKA: Yeah.
Awesome, awesome,
awesome, awesome.
So thank you.
We are going to do
a Q&A in a minute.
I just wanted to share that
in my experience of this,
literally, what I
got out of all this
was that I was trying
to fit into society.
I was trying to--
just doing it myself.
I was falling into
this game of popularity
and throwing parties
in high school.
I get into this fight, I end
up in conversion therapy,
and the whole purpose was
so I can be straight and fit
into society that way.
And that was the same goal.
And as I saw that
wasn't working,
I saw that my therapist
wanted the same thing.
I saw that my therapist wanted
to be a great therapist,
and all he was really doing
to try and succeed at that.
When I spoke to my
father, my father
wanted to be a great
dad, and he wanted
to ensure that I was one
going to have the greatest
future possible.
And when I spoke to Sam, and
what his high school experience
was about fitting in
and not being left out,
there was a pattern here
that, really, everyone
is looking to fit in.
People want to be acknowledged,
accepted, and loved.
And it could believe
even the person
you think as maybe your
enemy, the person who's
on the opposite
side of the aisle.
And as an LGBT activist,
I was seeing this not just
in the LGBT community like we
are standing to be accepted,
but so is everyone else.
And that's really what
I wanted to share today.
And it was a privilege to
bring my mom and Sam here.
And yeah, I just wanted
to present to you here
this is what our
story was, this is
what we experienced together.
And this is who we
are today, and we both
stand for making a
difference in the world.
And just, really, just
thank you for having us.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
So I know we're going to do a
Q&A. If anyone in the audience
has any questions,
there's two microphones.
I also know that there is--
people from their desk,
can ask questions, I was told.
I'm not a Googler or a Gaygler,
but I know they can do that.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Thanks for coming.
My question is it sounds like
you've rekindled, made amends
with a lot of people
that you had maybe
broken the relationship
with before,
whether it be your ex-therapist,
friends, whatever it is.
I'd imagine there's probably
some people you approached
that didn't go as well.
And I'm curious, how did
you approach that situation?
How did you overcome that?
MATTHEW SHURKA: Yeah.
Thank you.
Well, I did.
This is funny.
Sam and Steven-- so
Steven's obviously not here.
So he's the person who--
that didn't go that way.
So I called both of them.
I tried Steven once,
he didn't answer.
I think I left a voice--
I left him a voicemail.
And I think I waited a couple
weeks and I tried again.
And he picked up the phone, and
he didn't say hello, he just
said to me, I don't
know why you're calling.
I don't want to know
why you're calling.
And I don't want
you to try again.
And he hung up.
And I respected it.
I was proud of
myself for doing it.
I had the same apology
that I gave Sam.
That's why I was calling.
But I have to respect
people's wishes.
And I gave him that space.
And we have never spoken since.
And then Sam returned
my phone call.
And we had this incredible
conversation that
led to us being here today.
AUDIENCE: If I can
ask a follow up.
MATTHEW SHURKA: Yeah, yeah.
AUDIENCE: You talked about when
you called your old therapist
and he called you back.
And you saw his number, and
you don't want to pick up.
Sam, when you saw his number
come up, what did you do
and what was your response?
SAM MINER: It was totally fine.
It was like just
another call from you.
I think I called him back
as soon as I had a chance.
And one of our mutual
friends, David [INAUDIBLE],
sent me this text of Matt
on CNN, so when Matt called,
I was like, congratulations.
I saw you on TV.
MATTHEW SHURKA: This
is the weirdest moment
in the phone call.
SAM MINER: And that's how the
conversation just started.
I mean, I never like--
yes, I didn't like Matt,
but it was for silly reasons.
And I was just so past it.
MATTHEW SHURKA:
But why did you--
And now I have a question.
Why did you think I was calling?
SAM MINER: I had no idea.
MATTHEW SHURKA: It
was nine years later.
SAM MINER: I didn't
think about it.
MATTHEW SHURKA: OK.
You were just making--
you're making juice.
SAM MINER: I was making juice.
Yeah.
I was like, what
does he have to say?
I want to hear him out.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
MATTHEW SHURKA: Hey.
AUDIENCE: So I grew
up in South Florida
in an area that seems very
similar to you, Great Neck, so
a lot of Israelis, Jewish.
Wondering how much
of this do you think
is driven from the fact
that your father is Israeli?
Versus potentially the
fact that you may not
have had a bunch of
friends who are gay, who
are going through this as well?
Because one of my closest
friends, when I was growing up,
I personally think he's
gay, but he never came out.
He's married, he-- I think
has a pretty bad marriage.
And I think he's never come
out because his father is
like a extremely
staunch Israeli.
And just wondering--
MATTHEW SHURKA: I'm relating
to you, so this is why--
AUDIENCE: Yeah, yeah, yeah.
MATTHEW SHURKA: --I'm smiling.
AUDIENCE: I'm just
trying to understand
what the drivers were, and if
you think that it was leaning
one way or the other.
MATTHEW SHURKA: Yeah.
It's definitely an impact.
Culture does have an impact.
So first, my father is
Israeli, Iranian, Jew.
So that makes it that
much harder for him.
I actually don't come from
a very religious home.
I was raised traditional,
almost secular,
but we did every holiday, we
celebrated Shabbat dinners
every Friday, but it was
really out of tradition.
And my father was
this businessman.
And he just saw no
possibility of me
succeeding at all in
life, even though there's
an overwhelming
amount of evidence
that people can be openly gay
and succeed in their careers.
He just felt like--
my father hustled.
He's pretty much
an entrepreneur.
Didn't have an education,
and he succeeded.
And he felt like, there's no
way you're going to succeed.
And if this is
just in your head,
I'm going to help
you get rid of it.
And that was just
what he thought.
He still sort of thinks that.
I took the position to
love and accept him exactly
the way he is, and
that's really helped.
We have differences, but
I don't let that interfere
with the relationship.
And it's conversations.
For your friend, who knows?
That might really be
possible that he's
afraid of not being
loved and accepted
within his own family,
which is really
what the root of what the
whole talk is, is we're
looking for that.
And we may be
scared to come out,
because we don't even want to
know that we won't be loved
and accepted.
He knows he's loved
and accepted so far.
For you as a friend to him, the
advice I can offer you is just
love him every way he
is, and support him.
And being in this work,
I meet so many people who
are closeted or on the fence.
Something I keep
dealing with is I
keep dating guys who
are on the fence.
This is something that has
been a pattern that I still
haven't gotten rid of.
And it's sort of like,
I see how clear it is,
because of the field I'm
in and the world I came
from being in
conversion therapy.
Something like I always say,
you know, I can't pee for you.
And people just have to be
able to do it on their own,
if they ever choose to.
If they want to have their
full self-expression,
have their authenticity
to who they are.
And as a friend,
just no matter what,
love and knowledge
and support them.
If he's married,
love him that way.
If he chooses to come
out, love him that way.
Because he'll know that he's
in a safe space with you.
Yeah.
Thank you.
Yeah, hey.
AUDIENCE: What
advice do you have
for people who are-- gay
men who are dating someone
who has been through a traumatic
experience or conversion
therapy?
MATTHEW SHURKA: Yeah, what's
the advice for gay men
who are dating someone else
who's been through conversion
therapy?
AUDIENCE: No, like someone who
has not dating someone who is.
So if you could tell your
partners, if something
you wish they would know or do.
MATTHEW SHURKA: So just to make
sure I understand the question.
Let's say I'm a
person who did not
go through conversion therapy
but I'm dating someone who has.
AUDIENCE: Correct.
What advice do you
have for yourself then?
MATTHEW SHURKA: That's
a great question.
It also depends where the
person is along their journey,
because what we're seeing with
conversion-- former conversion
therapy patients-- it
becomes a lifelong challenge.
Especially for minors
who were in it,
there's a pattern of they
keep putting themselves back
into conversion therapy
because they believe
they failed the therapy.
I was one of them.
I put my-- at 19, my mother
and father were not in my life,
and I put myself back
into conversion therapy,
because I didn't
try hard enough.
And conversion therapists
will tell you that, too.
So there is so much that they
go through, even in the years
after.
I guess my advice
is really listen,
get where they're at,
what are they comfortable
with, what are they
not comfortable with.
And just so you can
be on their page.
So you know where they are.
You know what to expect.
If they're being-- if
they're telling you
that they were in
conversion therapy
and they're being open
with you enough about it,
and there's things that--
it sounds like-- I'm not
sure exactly what the
problem is specifically,
but there's a lot of--
one common thing is shame.
And when I came out of the
closet, I was not proud.
I came out not proud,
because I was like,
what if I made a mistake?
What if I want to go back
into conversion therapy?
What if I still want to
try and be heterosexual?
And I was out.
And it took about--
it took months,
and there was
specific people I met
who, I got like, I'm actually
great exactly the way I am,
and I can be proud of being gay.
So I really-- I think if you're
in a relationship with someone
who's been through
conversion therapy,
really want to listen to
them, hear where they're at.
And if you are
obviously willing to be
in that relationship with them,
and go through whatever they're
going through, just want
to love and support them
wherever they are.
And get to know what
your ex-- what to expect
and what not to expect.
And be good with it.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
MATTHEW SHURKA:
[? Cat, Cat, Cat. ?]
SPEAKER 1: Hi, do I know you?
[LAUGHS] All right.
So you said something
universal for me,
in when you came
out to your father.
And how he was like, I love
you, I'm there for you.
And then you went through
what you went through
in conversion therapy.
And it really struck me,
because when I came out
to my parents-- and Mathew and
I, we're two different people.
I identify as a lesbian.
I come from a family
of-- a Hispanic family,
very Catholic, very religious.
And my mom said the same thing.
She was the first
person I came out to.
And what was there was love
and acceptance immediately.
And I think that's always
there, especially with that bond
with a parent.
What's there is always
love and acceptance.
But the next day, they sat
me down and I was like, oh,
my god, why am I in trouble?
We had a little fireplace,
and they sat me down.
And they immediately wanted
me to stop hanging out
with my gay friends.
Like almost, what's the
source of the gayness?
Where's this coming from?
How is this happening?
It's like, oh, she's hanging
out with these gay friends.
They're a bad influence on her.
We have to bring
her back to church.
Maybe she needs to go
to military school.
And then started suppressing
my expression as well,
in the sense of I wasn't
allowed to wear certain things.
I wasn't allowed to
have my hair short.
And I know it wasn't
from a place of hate.
I know it was all
from a place of love.
And then I look at what's
going on in the country.
We have made so much progress
in the sense of LGBTQ rights.
And at the same time, too,
with this love and acceptance,
there comes this uprising
of discrimination laws
for different people.
And I almost wonder,
what do you think
is the source of that shame?
And how can we
impact the country
to really transform that
conversation for people
so we can impact it
on a larger level?
MATTHEW SHURKA: Yeah.
That's so great.
I think the biggest thing is
people sharing their stories.
Yes, we are passing laws,
and laws are very effective.
Yet it's not the thing that
shifts the public opinion
of a country.
Right now, what we're
seeing in North Carolina,
we're seeing in several
states about gay marriage,
there's a huge opposition to
our conversion therapy bills
that we're working to pass.
And just because
there's a law in place
doesn't mean the hearts and
minds-- the mind of hearts
have changed.
If I said that correctly.
And I think when people share
their stories, share openly
and authentically,
that's when people
get to relate to each other.
And that's what I
think what really
needs to be out there more.
You know, we're having a
conversation about bathrooms,
but where's the humanity in it?
And that's what I think needs--
what's so great what we're
doing here at Google
is there's a-- it's
a month-long series of
talks of people sharing.
Those are some of the strongest
and effective ways for people
to relate to each other.
[INAUDIBLE] we go through.
I come from a
conservative family.
And conversion therapy
broke my family apart.
When I tell that to Republicans,
that really touches them,
because they are all
about the American family
and the values of that.
Where, as a simple example.
You know, that's when it
gets really political.
What are those key points?
But I really think
the biggest things
is the storysharing,
people sharing themselves
authentically.
And that will also have laws
move along and move faster,
because people will start to
be compassionate, and relate
to them, and get the
importance of all those bills.
SPEAKER 1: Yeah, it's
interesting, too,
because I remember I had
a mentor in high school
when I came out, because
I was going through what
I was going through.
And he said, you know,
I come out every day.
I don't come out
once, and that's it.
I come out every day.
And I feel like that's
where a lot of us are, too.
We come out every
single day, just so we
can forward this conversation.
So thank you.
I want to also just
thank you for forwarding
that conversation of
love and acceptance.
I know we that conversation
with that, so thank you.
Forwarding the source.
Just getting to the root of it.
MATTHEW SHURKA:
Thank you, [? Cat. ?]
AUDIENCE: Yes.
[APPLAUSE]
MATTHEW SHURKA: Well, thank
you so much for having us.
Enjoy your Friday.
Enjoy the month of
pride here in New York.
A tremendous thank
you from all of us.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]